[Musica]
ho date di innovazione stava cambiando
la nostra società
la tecnologia si sta mangiando i mercati
non so chi di voi come me lavora a far
piccolo esperimento chi lavora nella
finanza
chi lavora nelle banche fate pure le
mani chi lavora nelle assicurazioni nel
commercio che c'è un negozio un punto
vendita lavora nel retail lavorano nella
logistica il nostro lavoro tra vent'anni
non esisterà più
tra vent'anni il nostro capo sarà un
software un bot che collegato a sistemi
di intelligenze artificiali prenderà
delle decisioni sulla base del big data
e dei social network quindi se pensiamo
insomma negli ultimi anni la
digitalizzazione di massa internet hanno
cambiato e stanno cambiando la nostra
società però nuove ondate di innovazione
stanno arrivando si chiamano blog chain
si chiamano stampa 3d si chiamano
fabbricazione digitale share in economy
la nuova organizzazione la conquista
dello spazio l'ultra broadband tutte le
parti quindi se pensate che avete visto
cose incredibili in questi 15 anni
beh allora la cia voci le cinture perché
sta arrivando una vera e propria
tempesta e francamente noi non abbiamo
ancora visto niente
io ho avuto la fortuna di occuparmi per
25 anni di innovazione di tecnologia di
start up di venture capital di
investimenti società tecnologiche e nel
95 la fortuna di andare a lavorare in
olivetti una italia online negli anni
nell'anno in cui nasceva il web negli
anni in cui internet era ancora una cosa
piccola una cosa poco conosciuta era in
bianco e nero la banda era poca c'erano
pochi utenti però era un posto dove
tutti i giorni succedeva qualcosa dove
tu la mattina andava in ufficio filo
garity collegavi qualcuno aveva messo un
pixel dei pixel rettangolare un
rettangolo di pixel
il primo banner questo qua e aveva
inventato la pubblicità online e chi
vedeva nascere questa cosa qua quel
giorno dietro vedeva la rivoluzione
della trasformazione che avevamo davanti
nei media nella comunicazione e nel
marketing
era nato il primo mass media
multimediale interattivo dell'umanità
poi l'altra mattina andava in ufficio e
su una pagina web
qualcuno aveva messo una libreria
c'erano un milione di libri e mandando
via email il tuo numero di carta di
credito
potevi riceverlo e dietro questa cosa
vedevi come sarebbe cambiato il retail
la distribuzione e il commercio la
vendita negozi oggi a milano in molte
città il più grosso competitor di
qualunque supermercato e amazon prime
compri e in un'ora chiare da tutto un
giorno scaricato il mio primo file mp3
io da ragazzo ci vuole musicista torino
è improvvisamente cosa ci ho visto
dietro questa cosa la possibilità per
milioni di musicisti di artisti di case
discografiche di cambiare il proprio
stato proprio accesso al pubblico la
possibile fatto che questa cosa avrebbe
cambiato la musica all'industria
musicale le case discografiche e questa
cosa qua in più per me rappresentava la
possibilità di mettere insieme due cose
che mi appassionavano la tecnologia
internet e la musica e la possibilità di
farci un azienda e fu quello il momento
in cui fece il passaggio diciamo da
manager e imprenditore ed è così fondai
la mia società la mia start up si
chiamava vitaminic una piattaforma che
consentisse a migliaia di artisti di
tutto il mondo di distribuire
commercializzare promuovere la propria
musica
fu quello il giorno in cui incontra i
sulla mia strada
il venture capital incontrai quello che
oggi poi diventato il mio lavoro e
incontra in particolare questa persona
il serino pioli serino è stato un
precursore del venture capital a livello
mondiale stato uno di quelli che lo
hanno inventato in quegli anni li dal
silicon valley da cupertino c'era una
piccola azienda software che si chiamava
apple che mandava i suoi uomini a ivrea
per scoprire cosa stesse facendo la
olivetti col venture capital e lui
racconta questo mestiere con una frase
che è molto molto bella molto diretta
come lui è molto esplicative dice guardi
dettori io ho investito nella mia vita
in 177 aziende tecnologiche
ho sempre investito in pmi erano sempre
tre ragazzi con un business plan in un
garage
non ho mai investito in aziende nane il
venture capital cerca imprenditori che
vogliono cambiare trasformare il mondo
ricordo in quegli anni che ero in
olivetti un giorno alla macchinetta del
caffè si è avvicinato un mio collega
americano e mi dice guarda gianluca mi
licenzio anzi mi sono licenziato
olivetti va da san francisco a fare una
start up
io devo dirvelo francamente il momento
pensai ma sei scemo cioè stiamo qua ci
siamo in olivetti è il migliore sta
esplodendo internet con tutto questa
cosa da fare l'azienda con due amici a
san francisco
poi un anno dopo mi manda un'email cessa
gianluca ti ricorda ho fondato la
startup st coletti al sito del master
tra due settimane ci contiamo in borsa e
lì lo scemo mi senti io e questa
sensazione di sentirmi io quello
sbagliato
su una cosa che caratterizzo morto di
quegli anni chiedevo in giro ai miei
amici ma davo in germania succede questa
stessa cosa di san francisco e tu in
francia ormai qua in italia non succede
quello che stiamo vedendo succedere che
gente come noi colleghi nella pausa
caffè fanno delle aziende che cambiano
il mondo è qua niente
all'inizio tende a pensare male ma ste
robe succedono in america se robe non
succedono in italia però poi alla fine
essenzialmente tendi a pensare che
quello sbagliato sei tu cioè che se sarà
il mio sono io che sono sono capace di
fare una roba così si vede che quello
era più bravo mi sembrava normale
sembrava come me ma forse più bravo di
me e quindi tendenzialmente la
sensazione di questo senso di
inadeguatezza che ci permeava poi anni
dopo capii che in effetti non era il
problema ma che la ragione era che
mancava un anello in questa catena ma
cava il venture capital mancava quello
che è con 350 mila euro e il serino
aveva consentito di trasformare un sogno
su un tovagliolo in una birreria con due
amici in un'azienda che un po nel suo
piccolo ha cambiato il mondo e così
quando sono uscito da quella esperienza
ho deciso di partire per un viaggio ci
siamo letteralmente comprati un camper
con i miei soci
abbiamo cominciato a battere l'italia in
giro per i territori e nelle città nelle
università networking per dimostrare a
noi stessi un assioma molto semplice che
il dna degli innovatori e degli
imprenditori è spalmato in maniera
omogenea su tutti i territori cioè che
non c'è una ragione strutturale genetica
tale per cui i nostri figli mia figlia
non in grado di fare la stessa cosa che
fa un mark zuckerberg a san francisco
che non sono loro il problema che siamo
noi il problema che intorno non c'è
quella stessa cosa ed è stato quello il
momento in cui abbiamo cominciato a
scoprire che questo mondo esiste anche
in italia anche grazie a internet
queste ondate di innovazione scateno
loro effetti non la scala diciamo così
logaritmica cioè quando l'onda è lontana
da una piccola increspatura di cui non
ti rendi conto ma poi quando a un certo
punto ti rendi conto dell'ora che vicina
è un muro di 30 metri che praticamente
ti lascia abbastanza atterrito per cui
se tu 15 anni fa faceva il tassista e
pensavi che tutta questa come la
digitalizzazione a te non ti avrebbe
spostato di un millimetro e non vedevi
che poi nasceva google maps arrivavano i
telefonini con il blog nel arrivavano
gli smartphone con le mappe e
praticamente succedevano tutte queste
cose intorno a te nun tene accorgevi che
a un certo punto c'era un imprenditore
che fondava una società che si chiama
hoover che cambiava completamente le
regole del mercato dei taxi a livello
mondiale
perché se tu sei hilton se il leader al
mondo negli alberghi c'hai 80 mila
stanze in 200 nazioni i canali
distributivi il brand le truppe
cammellate c'è un pescatore lontano di
tre ragazzini silicon valley che stanno
facendo un sito dove la gente può
condividere le case e quando l'onda si è
avvicinata ti sei reso conto e ten si è
reso conto il pane da che questi hanno 8
milioni distanze senza avere un albergo
e tu c'hai 80 mila stanze con tutte ste
maledetto infrastrutture ai costi da
gestire e non essere tenuto conto può
essere un problema
e di fronte a queste onde tutti noi
normalmente abbiamo una roba pop in aria
andiamo all'atteggiamento che può essere
o vediamo il rischio è siamo atterriti
di fronte a questo uno di 30 metri
il rischio di essere obsoleti ci
sentiamo ormai sorpassati non siamo in
grado di affrontarlo
il rischio di essere estromessi
completamente del mercato oppure ci sono
invece quelli che vedono l'opportunità
di cavalcare questa onda che rimescola i
mercati di trovare uno spazio in questo
muro dei 30 metri e uscirne fuori
vincitore che la rai nuova azienda
inventare nuovi servizi e cambiare il
mondo e in questo viaggio con questo
camper in giro per l'italia ha avuto la
possibilità di conoscere migliaia e
migliaia di personaggi come questi qua
fondatore di una startup italiana che si
chiama mashape 17 19 e 21 anni che
fondamentalmente è una generazione
diversa proprio in maniera radicale da
noi una generazione che questa gente
questi qua gente che ogni stato scrivere
software a 9 anni che quando arriva a
vent'anni in silico male questi li
chiamano signor ingegner fare il
direttore i tecnici di facebook e io
purtroppo si sa riconoscere migliaia di
ragazzi così è normalmente in quegli
anni come loro
questa gente qua non trovava spazio in
italia prendeva un aereo andava
dall'altra parte e aveva successo come
loro ma per fortuna da un lato grazie a
internet che rivende è uno strumento che
livella tutto dalle stesse informazioni
a tutti se le sei andare a prendere
questa cultura start up è arrivata
anch'essa in italia e sono nati un
intero movimento culturale noi stimiamo
20 30mila giovani che in questo momento
stanno facendo una startup tecnologica
per conquistare quelli mercati delle
onde che stanno arrivando gente come
vito lo mele che ha fondato jobrapido il
più grosso sito di annunci di per
trovare lavoro al mondo da milano con
200 persone ha conquistato il mondo è
stata acquisita la sua azienda dal daily
mail come davide dattoli che sta fuori
ha fondato il più grosso network di
coworking in europa come ugo parodi
giusino che 200 dipendenti da palermo a
palermo con sedi a roma milano
new york seul londra tokyo sta
conquistando il mondo della
distribuzione video online come i
fondatori di satisfy che stanno creando
un sistema di pagamento mobile per
diciamo combattere le carte di credito
sfruttando l'innovazione dovuta alla
nuova regolamentazione psd 2 che entra
in vigore quest'anno in europa o come i
fondatori di sarre decs per i quali sono
stato io quello che ha messo quei
150mila euro che ha consentito di uscire
da loro praticamente avevano ufficio
nella casa della nonna nella stalla
della nonna e oggi hanno generato 200
milioni di euro di transazioni con
moneta alternativa che in sardegna sta
rigenerando l'economia locale
mi occupo di venture capital per questo
perché fondamentalmente penso che questo
sia il momento di cominciare di nuovo a
parlare di sviluppo di competitività
l'innovazione di fare nuove aziende di
creare in questi nuovi posti di lavoro
perché io penso che fondamentalmente ci
sia un valore nei nostri territori e nei
nostri giovani i nostri figli perché
penso che sia il momento di tornare ad
investire nei nostri figli perché sono
loro che sono in grado di cavalcare
queste onde tecnologiche perché il
momento di tornare a investire
nell'economia reale grazie
[Applauso]